as i'm sure you know we've had lots of
stars of your movies on the show
and then i wasn't sure whether you knew
this or not but apparently you do
that matthew perry was on the show and
told this extraordinary
anecdote involving uh him
thinking he'd spent a night with you
but apparently there is you do know
about it and there is an m night
shyamalan twist to this anecdote well
yeah this is so he went on your show
and he tells the story of being out with
me all night
and then at the end of the night he's
having the greatest time and at the end
of the night he meets one of his friends
and and his friends like how's it going
and he says
it's the greatest night of my life i've
been hanging out with him night
shyamalan and then the guy turns and
says
that's not m shyamalan and he's been
hanging out with a random
indian dude all night long so that's the
story that matthew told
when he was on your show yeah but but
that so then i'm watching it
and here's the twist we did actually
hang out
that's that's what's that's actually
what's so astonishing
okay so i've i've pieced it together and
i have a
a amateur sleuth uh answer for what
happened so
we were hanging out we we were hanging
out and we were we were having fun
and and then we matthew's like let's go
to another place
and i'm like i'm you know what i'm i'm a
little tired i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna leave
here and you can go to the other place
meanwhile there's this kind of
fan that's been hanging about and he's
also indian and he's been a big fan he's
come over a couple times
wants to hang out with us and we're like
hey hey it's okay brother
and and he's over there and what i think
happened
is that matthew went on to continue
partying
and this other indian dude joined joined
him
and then later in that evening his
friend came over and said that's not m
night shyamalan and then matthew
thought he he second-guessed himself
that we actually had this evening
together
all these years later i have to see him
because i'm we did hang out we had a
great time and he was very funny
you